[music]
Hi, I'm Ramona J. Smith, Toastmasters
International 2018 World Champion of
Public Speaking.
Have you ever been asked to give a toast
but you didn't know what to say?
I know firsthand that speaking in front
of an audience is one of the most
demanding situations you can face.
Yet, I'm one of millions of people who
Toastmasters has helped gain the
confidence to communicate in all
circumstances.
When friends gather to celebrate, some
occasions are more formal than others.
But even a formal occasion doesn't have
to be intimidating.
The first tip will help you succeed with
any toast.
One,
keep it short and sweet.
One skill that Toastmasters learn is how
to get to the point.
With a toast, this is especially
important.
You want to stand up,
raise your glass, and say a few words to
make everyone smile, but do it in a way
that is brief and engaging.
Since you're keeping it to a few
minutes,
what should you talk about?
That might depend on the situation.
Toast happen at all types of events, not
just weddings.
For example, many memorial services
reserve time for guests to honor the
departed.
For a eulogy, it's a good idea to focus
on celebrating the positive and most
important parts of that person's life.
Highlight a few remarkable things that
they accomplished, but make it a short
list.
Platitudes, cliches, or long
chronologies may not only bore some
listeners, but they will steal the
impact of your message.
Instead, try to express what gave that
person joy and a sense of
accomplishment.
For a wedding, speak from the heart and
wish the couple well.
You might mention one aspect of their
relationship that you admire, but be
sure it's appropriate.
Two.
Be careful with humor.
Humor has a place in every toast,
regardless of the setting. Just remember
to be empathetic to the honoree and the
circumstances.
For a wedding toast, avoid potentially
embarrassing stories.
Risque jokes or anecdotes as a part of a
toast for any celebration can be
hazardous.
You're better off if you keep the focus
on the person or the event being honored
and not on the stories the couple, their
guests, or other honoree might find
uncomfortable.
Three.
Practice.
When your goal is a great toast,
practice at least once or twice before
the big event.
Rehearse the words you'd like to say,
but also plan an opening.
To begin, stand up,
raise your glass, and say, "I'd like to
propose a toast."
Then, practice giving your fellow
celebrants time to raise their glasses
before you speak.
Also, you may not have access to a
microphone. So, if you'll be addressing
a large gathering, it's a good idea to
practice projecting your voice.
Don't yell,
but breathe deeply and let your voice
radiate from your center.
Practice will help.
With a little preparation and practice,
you can master the art of toasting and
help make every celebration an event to
remember.
Cheers.
[music]